la posición de una partícula moviéndose
sobre la recta real está dada por esta
función s dt es igual a dos tercios de t
al cubo menos seis de cuadrada más de
este parate mayor igual a cero donde t
es el tiempo en segundos la partícula
simplemente se está moviendo en una sola
dimensión en una línea recta va ahí
viene la partícula se mueve tanto a la
derecha como a la izquierda durante los
primeros seis segundos cuál es la
distancia total recorrida por la
partícula durante el intervalo cero
menor o igual a t menor o igual a seis
bien es importante notar que nos están
preguntando por la distancia total que
recorre la partícula recordemos que la
distancia total es como sigue si la
partícula sale de este punto y se mueve
digamos tres unidades a la derecha y
luego se mueve cuatro unidades a la
izquierda
tenemos por acá que podría denotar como
menos 4 entonces la partícula terminaría
así asumo que esto es el cero en el
punto menos 1 entonces la distancia
total que recorrió es 3 unidades hacia
acá y luego 4 unidades hacia acá o sea
que la distancia total que recorrió la
partícula sería 7 a pesar de que la
distancia neta que se movía la partícula
solo es del -1 al 0 y esa distancia es
de menos 1 así que voy a considerar la
distancia sin signo ok entonces lo
primero que sería importante es
encontrar en qué puntos la partícula se
está moviendo a la derecha y en qué
punto se está moviendo hacia la
izquierda para hacer eso tenemos que
observar el comportamiento de la función
velocidad la velocidad de la partícula
va a indicarnos en qué dirección se
mueve si la velocidad es positiva la
partícula se está moviendo a la derecha
y si la velocidad es negativa la
partícula se está moviendo hacia la
izquierda bueno entonces a partir de
esta ecuación que tenemos de ese te
puedo calcular la velocidad de la
partícula ustedes ya saben muy bien que
la velocidad
una particular dada por una ecuación es
simplemente la derivada de esta función
de acá la derivada de la función de
posición sería dos tercios de la
derivada de t al cubo que sería 3t por
lo tanto sería 2 t cuadrada menos 12 t
- 12 t más 10 es la derivada ahora noten
que como hace una ecuación cuadrática yo
sé que es una parábola y como el
coeficiente cuadra tico este 2 es un
número positivo sé que es una parábola
que abre hacia arriba por lo tanto mi
parábola se debe de ver algo así que
bueno no sé si si este es el caso no
pero algo así vamos a tratar de graficar
la con más cuidado y bueno mientras la
velocidad esté por encima del eje x
entonces la velocidad es positiva en el
momento en el que baja es decir en este
caso aquí la velocidad es negativa por
lo tanto quiero encontrar esos puntos
pero antes que nada voy a encontrar las
raíces de esta parábola vamos a ver si
igual no está ecuación a cero si digo
que 2 t al cuadrado menos 12 t más 10 es
igual a cero entonces algo que puedo
hacer es dividir todo entre dos para
obtener t al cuadrado menos seis más 5
es igual a cero
y puedo factorizar esto como t menos 5 x
menos 1 ya saben estoy buscando dos
números cuyo producto hacia 5 y cuya
suma sea menos 6 esto tiene que ser
igual a cero por lo tanto alguno de
estos factores se tiene que anular y eso
me dice que
es igual a menos es igual a 5 perdón o t
es igual a 1 en cualquiera de estos dos
puntos la ecuación de la velocidad se
anula entonces si yo trazará mi gráficas
y pusiera aquí mi eje digamos btt
y aquí pusiera mi eje t
entonces yo sé que en los puntos 1 y 5
del eje de la parábola corta al eje
entonces 1 2 3 4 5 vamos a poner aquí
también el 6 bueno entonces la parábola
pasa por este punto y este putt perdón
no ese punto 1 2 3 4 5 por ese punto y
este punto aquí y como es una parábola
que se abre hacia arriba su vértice
tiene que estar justo sobre esta línea
que está dividiendo a la mitad de estos
dos puntos entonces la parábola se ve
algo así
bueno el chiste es que el vértice esté
justo debajo de el 3 pero bueno también
puedo encontrar cuánto vale ese punto
porque en ese punto si pongo t igual a 0
en esta ecuación simplemente me queda 10
por lo tanto ese punto de y el 10 este
punto aquí está igual a 1 este punto
está igual a 5 y más o menos así se ve
la gráfica de la velocidad
de modo que la partícula se mueve hacia
la derecha cuando está sobre este
segmento del 0 al 1 y del 5 al 6 en
estos dos cachos de la parábola la
velocidad es positiva y la velocidad es
negativa precisamente cuando la parábola
está por debajo del eje del eje x que es
precisamente aquí entre 1 y 5 así que
vamos a hacer una gráfica con las
posiciones de la partícula
vamos a poner aquí
el instante t y aquí la posición de la
partícula st ahora es importante notar
que ese dt no es lo mismo que vedette
ests está acá esa es la posición y esa
es la que realmente me importa entonces
en cero la partícula está en cero s de
cero es simplemente cero todo se anula
en uno la partícula está en dos tercios
menos seis más diez menos 610 es 44 y
dos tercios cuatro con dos tercios
luego también me interesa la partícula
en 5
el segundo 5 y en ese instante la
partícula está en dos tercios por 5 al
cubo 5 al qb 125 por 2 es 250 250 entre
- 6 por 5 al 4 225 6 por 25 cuánto es
125 150
150 más 10 por 5 de 50
entonces esto simplemente es menos 150
más 50 es menos 100 253 menos 100
tres porciones 350 3 y 2 y 50 tercios
cuánto es 16 con
16 x 36 48 me sobran dos tercios 16 con
dos tercios bien y en 6 en donde está la
partícula en el instante 6 pues ahora la
partícula va a estar en uf este se iba a
estar feo dos tercios por 6 al cubo
menos 6 por 6 al cuadrado que sería
menos 6 al cubo de nuevo más 10
por 6
y esto cuánto es pues puedo aquí
factorizar esto como 6 al cubo por dos
tercios menos 1
+ 60
esto es lo mismo que me muevo tantito
hacia abajo dos tercios menos uno sería
menos un tercio seis al cubo x menos un
tercio sería lo mismo que se hizo al
cuadrado por seis entre tres por menos
seis entre tres más sesenta y esto es lo
mismo que que 36 x menos 2
+ 60
36 x menos 2 es menos 72 más 60 y eso
simplemente es menos 12
- 12
bien entonces como decía estas son las
posiciones de la partícula y por lo
tanto la partícula recorre cuanto pues
para pasar de 0 a 4 con dos tercios
recorre cuatro con dos tercios
obviamente entonces recorre cuatro con
dos tercios unidades luego para pasar de
24 con dos tercios a 16 con dos tercios
siento que aquí me como un signo si en
efecto aquí me comí un signo porque
menos 150 más 50 es menos 100 y aquí es
250 menos 300 entre 3 menos 50 entre 3
así que esto en realidad es menos 16 con
dos tercios ahora cuánto se mueve la
partícula para ello de cuatro con dos
tercios a 16 con dos tercios pues se
mueve tiene que recorrer cuatro con dos
tercios para regresar al origen y luego
dieciséis con dos tercios para regresar
este punto entonces tiene cuatro con dos
tercios más
con dos tercios eso sería veinte con
cuatro tercios o 21 con un tercio
21 con un tercio
y ahora para pasar de este punto a este
ahora la partícula de nuevo se está
moviendo a la derecha tiene que tener un
cambio de cuatro con dos tercios de
nuevo
cuatro con dos tercios de nuevo bien
entonces cuando es todo esto si lo sumo
tengo dos tercias más dos tercios serían
cuatro tercios más un tercio serían
cinco tercios cinco tercios de primero
en otro
cinco tercios y ahora voy a sumar todo
lo que no son fracciones 44 28 más 21 es
29 29 más 5 tercios y 29 más 5 tercios
es simplemente cinco tercios es uno con
dos tercios por lo tanto esto es lo
mismo que treinta con dos tercios de
unidades esa es la distancia total que
recorrió la partícula